Candid Truth
What up everybody? Thank you for joining
us at Candid Truth. We're going to talk
about the truth and we're going to get
candid with it. There have been some
explosive
uh
I don't know what you want to call them,
epiphanies happening on the internet
right now. People are starting to wake
up. And the elites cannot stop this
message from coming out. They think they
can with censorship and all these
things, but they can't stop everyone,
right? So, the message is getting out
there and it's it's amazing to see
people waking up because God woke me up
in December 2011 when it came to things
like New World Order predictive
programming, symbolism, occult things,
all these things that are going on in
the world. And I remember I just started
blasting this stuff out on social media,
chemtrails and all these things, and
people just thought I was nuts. And I
lost a lot of friends, at least on
social media. And but over the years
I've seen the sleeping giant begin to
awake.
Now, when it gets to these kind of more
sensitive topics,
there's still a lot of sleeping people.
Jesus talked about
a parable about the the church, about 10
virgins. And all of them fell asleep.
So, the virgins are
are a parallel or uh what do you call
it? Like a symbol of the church. They
all had lamps with oil in them, but they
all fell asleep. The whole church fell
asleep. God's people fell asleep.
But right before the end, they all woke
up and five of them had enough oil to
get to the wedding and the other five
didn't. And they were trying, "Hey, can
we get some oil from you?" And they're
like, "If we give you some of ours, we
won't we won't make it either." And only
five of them made it. So, only half of
the church made it in the last days.
Because deception is on the rise like
never before. Think about AI and all
these things. We don't even know what we
can trust anymore. Things that we see,
we don't even know if we can trust our
own eyes anymore.
Let alone what you hear or or see on TV
or any of that stuff, right? So, when
they were asking Jesus, "What'll be the
sign of your coming?" The first thing he
said is, "Let no man deceive you."
What else was he talking about? He was
talking about false apostles,
wolves in sheep's clothing. He was
talking about Satan transforming himself
as an angel of light.
And that Satan's messengers can also
transform themselves of as ministers of
righteousness.
And yet, when we hear people say things
that we agree with, suddenly we attach
ourselves to them and say, "No, not him.
He's he's one of us. He's a good guy,
right?" That's what the disciples
thought about Judas. Think about that.
Judas was handpicked by Jesus to be a
disciple right there in the midst of
them. And he was doing everything they
were doing,
casting out devils and healing people.
And right there in the midst of Jesus
and the disciples, and yet he betrayed
Christ. He was filled with Satan.
I'm saying all this because
I I'm really just baffled. I'm
mind-blown that
we we used to have discernment. The
believers had discernment. We would we
recognize that, "Okay, just because he's
saying some things that sound right,
doesn't mean that he's 100%." He could
be a wolf in sheep's clothing. Um Satan
speaks in a lot of truths, right? In the
garden,
did not God say you could eat of every
tree?
Well, yeah, he did say that, but not
this one. You're forgetting the last
part. And 99% truth is not truth. And
so, there will be, especially in these
last days, there's going to be people
that sound just like us. The wheat and
the tares, right? The tares look so much
like the wheat that Jesus said, "Don't
don't pull them up lest you pull up the
wheat with it."
Wheat and tares look so close to each
other that you can't even tell them
apart.
Why are we not looking at the world
through that lens? Through a lens of
deception,
false apostles,
wolf in sheep's clothing, okay?
I'm trying to lay a foundation of
biblical truth here before I start
showing things that seem crazy or
conspiratorial or whatever. If you guys
have not watched the first video we did
on this Charlie Kirk thing, please watch
it. I know it's 2 hours and 20 minutes
or whatever, but it just has so much
information and I'm not going to keep
hammering I'm not going to keep beating
a dead horse. I'm not going to keep
saying the same stuff over and over. So,
if you haven't watched it, please go
over there and watch it. There's so many
things that people aren't talking about,
all these connections. And I want to
just like say them, but I can't I'm not
going to say them. You guys go watch
that video.
One thing I wanted to point out is
with what's going on with Turning Point,
is I believe this is the turning point
in history.
I've I've been saying for months, pretty
much since the beginning of this year,
that I believe 2025 is a big deal. It's,
you know, Trump is saying it's the
golden age and he wants to roll out AI
surveillance Stargate technology. You
see,
a lot of the believers,
the conservative right-wing people have
already fallen for the trap. We already
bought into like, "Oh, Trump, he's he's
going to save us. He's going to stop the
New World Order and all these things,
right?" And then he says, "Hey, I want
to roll out
total AI surveillance governance." Yeah,
the AI computers are going to govern
you. Isn't that great? It's called
Stargate, you know?
It is crazy that people don't see
you can't put your trust in men. Both
sides, left and right, are two wings of
the same bird.
Satan is at the top.
The Bible says we wrestle not against
flesh and blood, but against
principalities, against the rulers of
the darkness of this world.
That Satan is the god of this world. And
when have we ever been able to trust a
politician or a king? Wait was it
Pharaoh?
Wait was it Stalin? Was it Hitler? Which
one was trustworthy?
See, I think we've forgotten that we
can't put our trust in men, but we we've
lulled to sleep and we're like, "No,
things are good, you know? Like the
government
uh wants to help us and protect us and
they give us checks every once in a
while and food stamps and things like
this, right? Okay.
The whole thing is it's a system set up
against you. You can't just go out into
the woods, cut down some trees and build
a cabin and and live there and survive
off the grid. You can't do that because
somebody owns that land. You have to pay
property tax every year. Oh, you can't
use that wood because it hasn't been
graded by the government. It hasn't been
approved. All these things, it's a big
system. It's a system of lies that has
made you feel like you have freedom.
It's the illusion of freedom where you
get to choose your own slave master and
you get to work for that slave master
from 9:00 to 5:00, but you had a choice
about it, right? Okay, let's get into
this.
I've I've been paying attention to
what's going on at Turning Point. I
didn't watch the memorial
um
I'm there was a lot of stuff in there. I
saw some hand signs. I saw some
alarming things being said. And we know
according to prophecy that soon, I
believe very soon, there's going to be a
one world religion
enforced by a one world government on a
worldwide scale.
And there's already things in the works.
There's already laws on the books for
every state called blue laws. Those are
Sunday laws. That means when the mark of
the beast is set up, bam, they can
enforce religion
on
every 50 state in America.
Then it's going to go worldwide. But we
know according to prophecy, if you man,
check out the the mark of the beast
video we did. It's called Not a
Microchip. It's going to teach you a lot
about who the beast is, who the second
beast is, how America is going to cause
all the world to worship Rome, and how
America is the mirror image of the
beast, and how America is going to start
speaking like a dragon and is going to
start making laws that are identical to
what the what papal Rome was doing. What
did papal Rome say? If you don't worship
this way, you will burn at the stake.
And Revelation says that there will be a
one world religion
in the name of peace and safety, right?
And coexist in unity and all this stuff.
And if you don't worship this way,
well, you're not going to be able to buy
or sell. We're going to throw you in
prison. We're going to finally behead
you. These are the laws that are coming.
And I'm hearing things like that. Now,
I'm hearing uh cries out for civil war
and oh, we need the death penalty so
this guy can really get it. All these
things are purposefully being done.
Censorship. Don't you dare speak out
against this event because we will
cancel you. Censorship, death penalty,
um and the push for morality.
The push for we need to get everybody
back in church. Look, I'm all about
morality, but I'm all about freedom.
Freedom of choice, freedom of worship.
That's what this country is supposed to
be about, founded on freedom
of religion,
separation of church and state, not the
mingling of miry clay and iron, right?
Iron and clay, that's Rome and and
church-state system. Watch the mark of
the beast video.
As I'm looking at this Turning Point
thing, that's what I see. I see
Christian nationalism on the rise. I see
this big huge
quote-unquote memorial that's nothing
but a big political event full of MAGA
and right-wing
and everything that was being spoken
about, well, not everything. I I I
didn't watch it, but I saw some things
being said like
we need to go to church. We need to get
back in church, you know?
And I'm hearing some some terminology.
We're going to get into all that, but
what I'm doing is I'm setting up the
stage for
this was a political rally driven by
emotional manipulation.
All right?
What you saw happen,
I personally don't believe was reality.
I don't I don't believe politicians. I
don't believe people involved in
politics. I don't trust people who are
Christian nationalist. I don't trust
people who rub shoulders with Donald
Trump and are on
share the stage with him and have a
platform of the mainstream media
propaganda source. I already from the
top, I don't trust you. You have to
prove yourself to me.
When you're that high level, I believe
you're an insider, you're part of the
agenda, and you're you're just a
a plant, basically.
And you're being used to push an agenda.
What was that agenda? I believe it was
to push people to um
to believe in the
the idea that we need to keep a day of
rest, the importance of a day of rest,
one of the seven. I've heard Charlie say
these things. It doesn't really matter
what day, just as long as you keep one
of the seven. I know that's going to
trigger people cuz they're going to say,
"No, he said Friday to sunset and and
Sabbath to Saturday to sunset." Yes, he
did. He said that's the day he puts his
phone in the drawer and spends time with
his family. What was he doing on Sunday?
He was in the pews
at Calvary Chapel or somewhere taking
mass.
He was literally going to mass with his
Catholic Jesuit wife
who went to read who went to Regis
College, a Jesuit college. Look these
things up. She wears the Maltese cross
and crown necklace, which is all about
um Knights of Malta, which goes to the
Freemasons. All Look this stuff up.
Please do yourselves a favor and look
these things up. Now she's the
the CEO of Turning Point.
But I want you to notice something about
this logo. It's always been
a 180°
turn, which makes sense. Turning Point,
we're going to turn this country around
and you know, it does need a makeover.
This country needs to be turned around
for sure,
but these people work
in a method called order out of chaos.
So, we've had the chaos. I mean, we've
had the 86 genders and the the
child genital mutilation and all these
things. We had the chaos. Now, when
people start speaking logic and rational
thinking, it gets applauded and praised.
I agree, we need to come back to truth
and rational thinking,
but it's all order out of chaos. It's
all two steps forward, one step back.
So, this logo, the 180, makes sense.
Turning Point.
But when I saw this
logo right here, this is no longer a
180°
Turning Point logo.
This is something else.
I've never seen Turning Point use their
logo this way.
Look, up here is what what is we're
usually used to seeing. We're used to
seeing the curved arrow on the outside
of the word Turning Point USA. They
never use the logo as the O,
but for this huge event,
the memorial service and what's soon to
be the the tour that they're going on,
this is now the logo.
And if you don't know what this is,
we saw it back in 2016
when there was this whole interfaith
movement at the National Mall and
hundreds of thousands of people gathered
together
and notice the logo they used. Again,
this weird circle with a break in it.
This is not just some
creative way to do the letter O.
Nothing is by accident when it comes to
branding, when it comes to Hollywood,
when it comes to these agendas.
And this was a
Look how many sixes are on this picture
here. Six
six six. Very interesting. The website
was called Reset 2016. Wait, the event's
called Together. Why is it called Reset?
Hmm. Well, the logo that you're looking
at is an ouroboros.
The ouroboros is an ancient symbol of a
serpent or a dragon eating its own tail,
representing
eternity,
cyclical nature, and renewal. It
symbolizes the cyclical process of life
and death, the unending flow of time,
and the interconnectedness of all
things, appearing in ancient Egyptian,
Norse, and alchemical traditions to
illustrate concepts of universal
self-sustaining
cycle. This is
the furthest thing from Christianity
that you can get.
Alchemy?
Alchemy is a completely occultic satanic
merging of science and sorcery,
um trying to create life using the
occult magic.
Norse, Egyptian. Okay. Why the
ouroboros? It sounds like, "Oh, it's
just eternity, right?"
This is their logo. Together.
Turning Point.
You can see the serpent's mouth opened
as its tail is in its mouth.
I want to look up something because um
the Pope actually was a part of this
Together movement. What was their
Uh do I have Okay, I have their website
pulled up here.
Um Together 2016, a defining moment for
this generation.
The Assemblies of God is joining with
organizers of Together 2016 to promote
and endorse this national event designed
to draw the church from across the
nation and across denominations
merge This is a ecumenical push.
This is what the Pope has been trying to
do for years and years and years. If you
haven't seen the video of him saying
that all religions point to God,
whether you believe in Buddha or Hindu
or Muslim, as long as your desire is
pointing towards God, it it is God. It's
All these different religions are
different languages to God. And so, here
is this
interfaith movement across all
denominations in Washington, D.C. So,
here you have church and state mingling
together right there in the nation's
capital at the National Mall on July
16th to come together in unified prayer,
worship, and a call for catalytic
change. All right, change.
Remember, the website is called Reset
202016.
I think this is interesting because,
man, there's so I feel like that dude
with the the bulletin board that's
got the red thread and he's pinning
everything together because
everything does It goes together. What
does this word say? Nick Hall, founder
of Pulse.
Pulse, a ministry at the center of some
of the largest student-led prayer and
outreach. So, Pulse Pulse 2016 Pulse.
What
What else did we see?
Pulse 2016.
Oh, yeah, Pul- Pulse Orlando
2016. That was a month prior. This was
June
before
July happened.
Uh
I need to pull up that logo again.
So, this happened in July,
a month after this event
where some a shooting happened at a
nightclub, uh a gay nightclub called
Pulse in Orlando, and it was in 2016.
And this happened a month prior. And
look what the signs say. Love wins,
right? Oh, we just need to come together
and unite because love wins.
And so, you have the Christians getting
together and saying, "Yeah, let's let's
come together."
And it's it just so happens to be put on
by a magazine called Pulse in the same
year, literally a month later.
I just think that's a ironic
coincidence. Here's the website.
Reset 2016.
It's kind of a broken website. There's
really not much going on on here, but
you see that it had uh bands like Kari
Jobe and Crowder and Hillsong United and
Nick Hall and Francis Chan and Ravi
Zacharias and Lecrae. A lot of these
bands were actually at this memorial
that just happened.
The one that seated 90,000 people that
literally
uh was launched in 11 days.
Charlie Kirk got assassinated at around
noon
on the 10th
and at 7:00 a.m. on the 21st, this thing
was
going off.
11 days
from death
to huge rally.
I I think that's
I think there's something fishy about
that. I don't know how you can
get the venue, book all the bands, have
all the speakers that are literally from
the White House,
um hire all the security, all the the
parking people,
the vendors,
the t-shirts, like everything
in 11 days. Pyrotechnics,
LED screens, motion graphics, video,
all this stuff in 11 days. I I find it
very hard to believe. Um I did a little
quick search, how long does it take to
do a lot of these events that have
thousands of people? And it's always
like 6 months to a year or two.
That's how long it takes to do an event
like, I don't know, a TED Talk. A TED
Talk that has usually 2,000 people
takes anywhere from 6 months to a couple
years
or 6 months to a year or something.
This one had 90,000 people.
So, that word reset was sticking out to
me, reset 2016. And so, I was like,
wait, 2016, when did we start hearing
about that word reset? And I said, when
did the phrase the great reset first get
started and become popular
in current politics? And it says, the
phrase great reset first gained traction
in political discourse after the World
Economic Forum launched its initiative
of that of that name in June 2020.
However, the term was originally coined
a decade earlier. So,
we see this big push
for together,
unite all religions together. The Pope
was pushing this thing. I wish I could
get it to show that. Yeah, let's see.
The Pope was all about this thing. He
was
one of the sponsors or or something. He
had something to do with this movement.
And he's saying all religions are the
same. They're just different languages
of God. And we're going to call the
website reset
20 2016.
You can't see the website on here, but
uh reset 2016. And we have the Ouroboros
on there.
And it's all about death and renewal and
rebirth.
Think about that.
Remember what the Ouroboros means.
Death, rebirth, recycle,
eternity, all these things. It's an
occult meaning, and I'm going to show
you what that means.
Then in
you know, 2020, we start hearing this
phrase again, the great reset. Oh, in
2020.
Now, this was a video. I really
encourage everyone to watch it.
Um it's on our channel. It's on Candid
Truth under the live tab. Most of our
videos are live.
And man, I I keep pointing people back
to this video. It's called
the deception is stronger than you
think. And this was
right after the
assassination on Trump
where
an assault rifle hit his ear.
He fell behind a pulpit for a little
while, came up with some blood, and was,
you know, security guards let him stand
up and hold his fist up in the air. And
a week later,
didn't even have a scab on his ear.
And he said, oh, I'm a fast healer when
somebody asked him about his ear when he
was at a press conference a week later.
Come on, man. An assault rifle hit your
ear, and you're wearing a a patch on it.
And everyone who idolizes you started
wearing that patch in honor of you. But
a week later, there's no scab. Okay.
Now, his hat said 45 47. And if you add
those numbers together, 45 is nine, 47
is 11. That's not just some mere
coincidence. 9/11 is a big deal in the
occult, in these esoteric meanings.
It's order out of chaos. It's the
phoenix rising out of the ashes. It's
the Ouroboros.
And when I was putting this message
together, putting this presentation
together, I really feel like the Holy
Spirit was leading me to some things
that I had never really seen before.
And it's in this video, and I I'm going
to play it because
I I just can't
I can't say enough how many people need
to watch this video. It's an hour 19
minutes, but I'm not going to play all
that, obviously.
I'm going to play this one portion,
though, because it's very eye-opening
about
what the ritual of 9/11 is.
When you combine those numbers together,
it's all about order out of chaos. It's
all about phoenix rising out of the
ashes. It's all about the Ouroboros.
Check this out.
Because it's so deep.
The number nine, the numerology
numerological number nine. Now, this is
from ChatGPT. This is not like
Wikipedia.
ChatGPT is scouring the entire
information of the world and giving you
a a juiced version of it. And this is
what it said.
It said, number nine represents
completion, endings, and transformation.
Wait a minute.
Completion of what? Ending of what?
Transformation?
It is often seen as the last number
before the cycle begins anew.
Huh, okay.
Try tying to themes of judgment,
culmination,
or the end of an era.
What happened after 9/11? That's when
all of our freedom started really going
away, right? Being stripped big time.
The Patriot Act. They give it this
friendly name, the Patriot Act. Oh, it's
I'm a patriot. I Yeah, I want to get
frisked and scanned and metal detected
every time I go through the TSA. I want
them to just feel me up.
This is when your freedom started going
away, being stripped. 9/11.
Why?
Because it was the beginning of a
transformation. It was the end of one
era and the beginning of a new era.
It is also associated with spiritual
enlightenment, altrol
ultraism,
and universal consciousness.
Universal consciousness, this is the age
of Aquarius. This is one world religion.
This is where all this is coming to.
This is Luciferianism. The one world
conscious and universal consciousness,
whether it's new age or occult or
whatever it is,
is all about worship to Lucifer.
Satan.
However, in the context of the occult,
nine can symbolize the culmination of a
ritual or the birthing of something new
through destruction.
Wait a minute. Wait. The the beginning a
new era
a new era of
universal consciousness that starts
with destruction.
Starts with destruction.
What happened at 9/11?
That was a ritual.
That was an occult ritual that brought
in the new era.
This stuff is so deep, guys.
Number 11,
considered a master number in
numerology, 11 is linked to intuition,
spiritual insight, and the gateway
between the material and the spiritual
world?
This is why they love Halloween so much
and push that, too, because
that's when they say the veil is the
thinnest between the spiritual world and
the physical world. 11. Okay, so you got
the beginning of a new universal
consciousness starting with destruction
with number nine.
And now you got the gateway between the
material and the spiritual worlds.
It also represents duality and balance,
two pillars, good and evil, male and
female. When you look at the Masonic uh
apron, that's one of the things, you'll
see those pillars with the globes on
top. There's pillars on either side.
That's what this is about. That's 11.
Duality, that's the balance of good and
evil, the yin and the yang. This stuff
is worldwide. This is a worldwide
deception.
Duality is not good. The Bible says that
we should not fellowship with darkness.
Light cannot mingle with darkness.
It says, in occult context, 11 often
symbolizes a disruption of order. Okay,
wait a minute. A disruption of order?
So, there was order, but now we're going
to bring in some new era.
Representing
the chaos that precedes the creation of
something new.
Precedes It's precedes means before.
So, if you got not after, precedes. So,
there was chaos that precedes a new
order
of duality and a gateway between
spiritual worlds. Aleister Crowley, a
prominent occultist, emphasized the
number 11 as being tied to magic,
will, and the manipulation of reality.
Oh my goodness, the manipulation of
reality. Are we dealing with something
today
that is like a blending, and we can't
even tell if it's real or not, right?
AI. Like we're literally virtual
reality, metaverse, all these things,
augmented reality. We're blending things
and it's never been this way. When I was
growing up, it was VHS and Nintendo.
We dreamed of having VR headsets. And
now we're in the world where you just
type something and it comes to life, and
you You animate it, and you can put
yourself and you can immerse yourself in
that world. I see videos and pictures. I
I understand I I mess with AI images a
lot. So, I can usually kind of spot it
out, but
if you didn't know, if you're not
familiar with AI and what it looks like,
it's impossible to tell the difference,
especially now. It's getting worse and
worse.
Okay, I I was talking about this
in light of the first, quote unquote,
>> assassination
on on Trump's ear.
And I was talking about how it's
manipulating your reality. Everybody was
like, everybody got caught up in that
thing, right?
He won the election because of that, and
I don't even believe the election votes
count or anything, but it deceived
everyone into thinking that their guy
won because suddenly
everybody was all about Trump. Even
celebrities that hated Trump the first
time were all promoting him. People like
Snoop Dogg and stuff.
It's crazy. Um
but there's this thing is still going
on. So, nine means
the destruction.
And 11 means the rebuilding.
You got to You got to see this. When you
put the two together,
it's about creating a new system
replacing the old system because of of
destruction. So, those buildings were
purposefully built to be destroyed. It
was a ritual from the very beginning.
And when they crumbled down, demolition
style, they were replaced with the One
World Tower.
The One World Tower.
Listen, it keeps going. Well, it's
getting better and better, which is
worse for us.
But, AI, as good as it is
of reality. Now, notice it says magic
with a K. That's Aleister Crowley's
magic
nations.
The reality of what's Oh, oh my vote
counts. Combine that nine with that 11.
Symbolic combinations of nine and 11.
When nine and 11 are placed together,
the numbers can significa can signify a
transition through what? Destruction.
A transition through destruction.
The ending of an old order
and the opening of a gateway to a new
paradigm. Are you guys hearing this,
man?
Are you guys hearing this? Something had
to be destroyed.
Like towers for this ritual, for these
magicians that are just Okay.
I'm not going to keep playing it, but
look what it says.
When nine and 11 are placed together,
the numbers can significat significat
signify a transition through
destruction.
The ending
of an old order, the opening of a
gateway to a new paradigm.
This mirrors the occult idea that order
or destruction is necessary
to create order or manifest a new
reality.
Now, that is so important because
that's what happened at 9/11. When those
towers came down, the world was no
longer the same, was it?
Was the world the same after those
towers came down? No way.
They
erected
one tower in its place called the One
World Tower, and our whole world was
changed, or at least our country was
changed.
Now, what has happened?
What has happened just now?
Something or someone
was destroyed
either metaphorically or literally. I'm
not going to get into all that, but that
when you listen to this, it can happen
even metaphorically, even like a
ritualistically. It doesn't have to be
literal.
This
person was taken out
and a new order is is coming.
And the ouroboros, that's what the
ouroboros is all about. That's what this
symbol is all about.
It's about the phoenix rising out of the
ashes. If you haven't watched the first
video, I'm telling you over and over,
watch the first video on the Charlie
Kirk thing because
Turning Point is based out of Phoenix,
Phoenix, Arizona.
Erica
uh Erica Kirk, her name means a a
renowned eternal ruler and all these
things.
She's actually talking to the camera
saying, "You don't know what you have
just ignited." She's using all these
trigger words about fire, about
basically death and destruction and
renewal, right?
And it happened again
uh at this memorial. Those types of
things are being talked about.
So,
keep all that in mind.
Today
I I actually saw some hints of this um
the other day about
predictive programming in the movie
Snake Eyes,
but today, I think it was
WorldStarHipHop shared this. And when
WorldStarHipHop shares something, it's
going to go viral. I mean, that's what
they are, viral content. And so, they
were talking about how the movie Snake
Eyes was predictive programming about
what happened at this event. Look what
it says here.
"Believe everything except your eyes." I
think that's very interesting slogan for
a movie like this. Look at this hand
sign that's going on. What is this hand
sign? I actually seen Charlie doing that
hand sign. Check this out.
Hm, that is a Masonic hand sign.
Interesting that that's on the cover of
the movie.
And what is the movie about?
It says
um
Actually, you know what? I'll I'll read
this this guy's article cuz he did a
good job breaking it down.
This is Hidden America.
Thrice the greatest. I I can't Yeah,
that's what it says.
And um 1998
Brian De Palma film Snake Eyes is about
a politician named Charles
Kirkland. Charles Kirkland, Charlie
Kirk. Who is assassinated by getting
shot in the neck. Charles Kirkland
equals Charlie Kirk. Is that a stretch?
Well, the assassination occurs during a
heavyweight boxing match. The boxer who
takes a fall during the film is named
Lincoln Tyler.
Wasn't there a Tyler in this event?
Yeah, we see it right here in this
picture.
Tyler Robinson
is the suspect who did who caused the
assassination on Charlie.
The name Tyler
is a senior officer in a Masonic lodge
responsible for guarding the lodge door
and ensuring only qualified individuals
enter.
Very interesting.
Um it says
that in the film, let's see actually.
Okay, so I just read that. In the film,
Lincoln Tyler is known as the Atlantic
City Executioner.
The fight in the film occurs on
September 10th,
the same day as Charlie Kirk's death.
The film was shot on location at the
Trump Taj Mahal in Atlantic City. Trump
was a close ally of Kirk.
The character Gilbert Powell in the film
was literally based on Donald Trump,
according to Internet Movie Database.
So, in the movie, there's a character
literally based off of Trump.
And the And it's shot on location at the
Trump Taj Mahal.
And it was about a politician
being shot in the neck whose name was
Charles Kirkland.
Interesting.
In the film, the patsy is the
Palestinian terrorist who mentions an
Israeli arms deal. As the movie poster
says, believe everything but your eyes.
Now,
there's some things that were not
pointed out in here.
Um notice the Masonic hand sign again.
This character was actually based on
Donald Trump.
Um
it was at the Trump Taj Mahal. Now, some
people are saying that
this poster does not say September 10th.
It is blurry.
But, it looks that looks like these
numbers. That looks like 10.
They're They're saying it's uh September
19th.
But, it could be September 10th.
I mean, that 1 0 looks like this 1 0 to
me.
The Atlantic City. What was not pointed
out in this was that it says Atlantic.
I'm going to I'm going to touch on that,
but first I want to mention
that when you see this billboard in the
background, it's on a newscast.
And the the weather lady is
announcing that there is a storm.
And I have the script here
somewhere.
So, I I asked AI, was there a a
newscaster announcing a storm? It says,
"In the 1998 film Snake Eyes, the woman
newscaster announces the storm is
actress Jane, whoever."
So,
yes, there's a woman that announces a
storm. I have the script right here.
So, this is the script. It's very long,
but I did a a word search on
on the word storm and it says they're
talking to her. They're saying, "Cut,
cut. Athena, they want you to call it a
tropical storm, not a hurricane." So, in
the movie, there's a hurricane coming.
The hurricane's name is Jezebel.
And they said, "We don't want you to
call it a hurricane. Tell the public
it's just a tropical storm because we
want people to still come to this fight
tonight." They didn't want to distract
people from coming to the fight. So,
she called it a storm.
Now, in this scene, a lady's talking
about a tropical storm, a very
high-winded storm, and she's avoiding
the word hurricane. And in the
background behind her
is September 10th and it says Tyler the
Executioner,
which that's what we're seeing right now
in today's current events.
And it's talking about Atlantic City.
So,
what is a What's another word for a
storm? A violent windy storm is a
tempest,
right? A violent windy storm is called a
tempest. This storm is a very
significant in the movie. I've never
seen Snake Eyes, but just the research
I've done, this hurricane Jezebel is a
is a big deal in the movie.
But they wanted her to call it a storm,
which is Tempest. Do you know that there
is a move is a show, a series on Hulu
and Disney Plus
called Tempest?
It's a K-drama, meaning it's a Korean
drama, and I want you to pay attention.
I'm not going to play the audio, but I
want you to pay attention to
what the plot is talking about here.
So, it says, "Who are you?"
Um
There's a guy, he pulls out a gun, he
shoots this politician who's a
Republican politician, a woman in white.
Look at this.
The woman in white, do you remember
Charlie Kirk's memorial, a woman in
white?
There's also a woman in white in the
movie Snake Eyes, ironically.
Uh let me see if I can pull that up,
actually.
This is This is very
very interesting. If this is all a
coincidence, this is this is crazy.
See this woman in white? Where she at?
Is she on the couch over here?
This woman right here, she is one of the
witnesses.
A woman in white.
That whole deal with the Charlie Kirk
and all that stuff.
Let me get back to my tab here.
Now, here we see
an assassin walk into a church.
Do you know what the name Kirk means?
Church. Look it up. I could look it up
for you. It's in the last video.
Kirk means church.
The Kirks are Christian. So, and and
Erica Kirk is a Catholic.
So, here's this Catholic church, this
guy comes out, pulls a gun,
shoots. They don't show it in the
trailer, but he gets shot in the neck.
I'm going to play it right here.
Coincidence?
Is that a coincidence?
Now, watch what it says.
"Why did you Why did you come to me?"
Jang Jin- Jin-ik
of the New Republican Party has been
shot.
Republican Party. I didn't even know
Korea had
Republican, Democrat, all this two-party
stuff.
"Our client wants to be your bodyguard,
but keep it a secret." What does that
mean?
Widow of South Widow of South Korea
politician. So, now we have a widow
wearing white of a
Republican politician. Interesting.
Uh "To the public, you're Joan of Arc."
This stuff gets so deep. I I just want
to keep going on rabbit trails here
because I forgot to
to put some of these things in here.
Check this out.
Joan of Arc
Kirk.
Joan of Arc.
Look at this. Joan of Arc Kirk refers to
the conservative commentator
Charlie Kirk, who was assassinated in
September 2025 and was compared to Joan
of Arc by right-wing commentaries due to
his prominent prominent and
controversial stance on American
politics.
I mean, how can there be so many
coincidences?
Joan of Arc.
They just said they consider you
Joan of Arc. To the public, you're Joan
of Arc.
Wow.
The woman who stood in front of
a shooter to save her husband.
Watch out for this man.
I'll take care of her. I don't know if
it shows everything in this trailer.
Um
You see she's
meeting outside of this um statue, this
religious statue.
Okay, stick with me, guys.
So, in this movie, she's a Christian.
Goes to Catholic church, crosses,
everything. I didn't know South Korea
had any Christianity, but I looked it
up. It's actually on the rise. Now,
this
is a review of the show.
Now, what I forgot to mention What I
forgot to mention,
when did this show come out?
When did
the Hulu show
Tempest
best
premier?
Oh.
Oh, wait a minute.
What's that?
September 10th
of this year. Wait a minute. It
This show literally aired
the very day, the first episode which
showed the Republican politician get
shot in the neck in a church with a
woman in white who's actually going to
take his position.
She takes his position
premiered on September 10th, the same
day.
The same exact day.
Wow.
So, I I might not even have to show you
this whole thing. The The main thing I
was going to show you in this was that
um
she does take over.
She's going to take over. They wanted
They thought about maybe um the son
should take over, but she was like, "No,
I'm going to take over." We have got to
the point where literally
and I don't
have to watch through these uh
have to watch through the ads.
So,
in the show, she actually gets a
necklace from her husband after he dies.
Well,
it's interesting. It's her necklace, the
husband grabs it as he's dying, he
bleeds all over it, and she doesn't see
it again until this guy brings it back
to her and gives her the bloody cross
necklace.
Do you know that's exactly what's
happened right now?
I'm going to try to find this scene.
She's talking to the Catholic priest
and right here,
this guy hands her a cross necklace.
It's her own cross necklace that she was
wearing when her husband died and he
pulled it off her neck.
Now, check out what's going on right now
in current politics.
Erica Kirk necklace.
Erica Kirk wears her husband's,
Charlie's, blood-stained pendant.
Blood-stained pendant that was ripped
off from his neck.
And it says,
"Grieving widow Erica Kirk has revealed
she wears a blood-stained pendant of St.
Michael."
That's very Catholic, by the way.
Charlie Kirk um is not who you think he
is.
"Of St. Michael that her husband Charlie
was wearing when he was shot. The small
icon with blood traces in the
crevice of the cross was ripped from
Kirk's body."
So, she's now wearing
a blood-covered cross from her husband
who was shot in the neck on September
10th, the same exact storyline that's
happening in the Tempest.
This is predictive programming, guys.
Predictive programming is
it's Satan's counterfeit of prophecy.
God says, "I will not do anything unless
I reveal it to my prophets first,
right?" Everything he does is in in
prophecy. So, Satan counterfeits
everything that God does, and he says,
"Okay, God's got prophecies, I got my
own prophecies. I'm going to put them in
my Bibles, which are the movies."
Because all of these movies' storylines
are basically saying that God is the
villain and Satan is the hero.
That Thanos, the a one evil villain that
sits on a throne in the spaceship in the
heavens is coming to Earth to snap his
fingers and destroy half of humanity.
The spaceship is called the Sanctuary.
That is God. That is Christ. And yet
he's the villain. And who are the
heroes? They're all these mutants and
beings that are based off of Roman and
Greek gods.
And you And you'll see it over and over
and over. We've talked about this topic
a lot. So, Satan says, "I will put my
prophecies in the movies."
So, remember, the word Atlantic was on
this
uh on this picture back here.
Atlantic City.
So, I wanted to to see
what the significance was of Atlantic. I
look up Atlantic.
Where does it originate? Where does that
word originate from?
It says Atlantic Ocean, all this stuff.
Here we go. Origin.
Atlas.
Notice it says Atlas right here. Atlas.
Again, Atlas.
Atlantic. Okay, so the word Atlas became
the word Atlantic.
Why is Atlas important?
So, I asked, "Does Atlas have any
connections to Atlantis?"
Yes, the two are directly connected
through Greek myth, according to Plato.
The mythical island kingdom of Atlantis
was named after the first king, Atlas,
who was the eldest son of Poseidon,
Plato's account account in his
dialogues. Okay.
So, why is Atlantis
and Atlas important today?
Because I said, "Does Atlantis have any
connection to the golden age?" If you
guys have not seen these videos, our
past videos under our live tabs, Trump
is all about saying, "We're going into a
golden age." The golden age is the age
of Aquarius. This is the age that Helen
Blavatsky and um
Alice Bailey predicted in 2025 would be
the age of Aquarius when we enter into a
new shift where spiritual beings were
going to enter our world and they called
it the the hierarchy, the um
I don't know why I can't think of it
right now. The hierarchy of
Somebody tell me in the chat.
But, it's talking about when the
spiritual beings, demons, are going to
manifest into our world. I know
somebody's got it in here.
The
Help me out, guys.
Hierarchy. Hierarchy. Why can't I think
of it? Anyway, Alice Bailey,
the hierarchy.
Why is Trump talking about the golden
age?
Why is he talking about the age of
Aquarius? How come this movie back in
is talking about Atlantic City, Tyler,
September 10th,
um Charles Kirkland,
externalization of the hierarchy. Thank
you, Emma.
Thank you so much.
So,
Alice Bailey was talking about the
externalization of the hierarchy would
happen in the golden age. In the year
2025, specifically. What do we see
happening right now?
The military has been for years now, the
past few years, four or five years, has
been saying, "Oh, yeah, UFOs are real.
We see them every day."
Then they say, "Oh, we actually talk to
non-human intelligences. Yeah, we don't
know if they're alien. They could be
interdimensional beings, but we talk to
them. We communicate with non-human
intelligences and have been since the
1930s. They're prepping humanity to
receive demonic entities into this world
and to think that they're just visitors
from far distant galaxies that are here
to protect us, that are here to keep us
from destroying ourselves or the
environment and all these things.
And so, we just got out of this chaotic
world. Well, we're not out of it yet.
We're still in a chaotic world, but
there's all this promise of bringing
order
and AI surveillance. And wait a minute.
A scientist from Harvard is telling us
right now that in November, hostile
aliens are going to be here.
Have you heard about that? We did a
video on that. It's one of the most
viewed
videos.
And what is it called? Ha.
None other than three-eyed Atlas.
Remember, Atlas, Atlantis,
Atlantic, Age of Aquarius. All of it is
coming together.
Full circle, like an ouroboros.
Like the phoenix rising out of the
ashes.
Is this the last line?
Um
if you read Revelation
and you read what the what all's
supposed to happen prophetically,
we know that the dragon is wroth with
the woman who keep the commandments of
God. There's a remnant of God's people
who are keeping the commandments of God
and they have right to the tree of life
and the gates into the city.
There's going to be a lot of people that
say, "Lord, Lord, didn't we do all these
things in your name?" He's going to say,
"Depart from me. I never knew you, you
workers of lawlessness."
There's coming a time very soon where a
one-world religion is going to be
enforced by law. And if you do not
worship according to that way, that
false way,
you will lose your life.
You will not be able to buy and sell.
You're going to be beheaded, all these
things.
We are on the brink of great deception,
where it's going to look like peace and
safety, where visitants from far distant
galaxies, who are nothing but demons in
disguise, are going to physically
manifest in our world and we're going to
have to think some
We're going to have to rethink
everything we've ever believed.
Do I believe what the word of God says?
That there's demons coming in disguise
that are going to round up the
militaries of the world to fight Christ?
Or do I believe that these are just
visitants from far distant galaxies who
seated us here on Earth and they they're
higher evolved beings who have reached
Christ consciousness and all these
things? We're going to be face-to-face
with supernatural things that we've
never experienced in our entire lives.
And it's crazy that this predictive
programming had all the little phrases.
Atlantic,
Tyler, Charles Kirkland,
September 10th,
and then we had this movie this show
called Tempest
with the same thing.
The same message.
And at the memorial, this was said.
Because remember, it's the dragon,
right? Satan is the dragon, that great
dragon, that serpent of old who's
deceiving the entire world. Listen to
what was said at his memorial. Our
lineage and our legacy
hails back
to Rome. And to those trying to incite
violence against us,
those trying to foment hate, you cannot
defeat us, you cannot slow us, you
cannot stop us, you cannot deter us.
We will carry Charlie and Erica in our
heart every single day and fight that
much harder because of what you did to
us.
You have no idea the dragon you have
awakened.
Isn't that interesting?
This
memorial, this quote-unquote memorial
service for Charlie Kirk, was nothing
more than an ecumenical push towards a
one-world religion under
uh
emotional manipulation
with pyrotechnics and bands and
people that we idolize
as they literally say, "We are Rome."
Who was a system that enforced religion
by death decree.
And because of what you've done, you've
awakened the dragon, Satan,
that dragon, that serpent of old who's
going to bring about a one-world
religion. And if you are so confused
right now, because wait a minute, these
people are Christian. How can Christian
be the antichrist? How can Christianity
be the mark of the beast? Because it's
going to look so close to the truth that
Christians are going to fall for this if
they don't understand Bible prophecy and
understand that Satan is going to appear
as Christ and he's going to be doing
lying signs and wonders and
miracle-working demons are going to
deceive the entire world, then you are
going to be deceived
and you're going to take the mark of the
beast.
Because the mark of the beast can be
taken in the hand or in the forehead.
That means in the beliefs of your mind
or by the works of your hands. So,
there's going to be a lot of people that
say, "Wait a minute, this is all about
peace and safety, unity and coexist. You
know what? We We really do all believe
the same way. We just have different
ways of of thinking about it."
What is his name? Uh Chris Bledsoe.
Chris Bledsoe is a self-professed
Christian who had an experience with you
UFOs and aliens and he sees them all the
time and he sees a woman, a supernatural
woman named Hathor, which is a Egyptian
goddess.
And he says, "I believe she's the Holy
Spirit."
So, soon we're going to be merging
paganism and Christianity. It's going to
be like, "Look, the Egyptians thought
she was Hathor, the Christians think
she's the Holy Spirit, uh these people
think she's Isis."
And because we've never been faced with
a
supernatural beings and because we think
that Satan is scary and he has horns and
he wants to you know, kill everybody.
When he comes in the name of peace and
safety and coexist and unity and love,
millions of Christians are going to fall
for this and say, "Look, we've all
want to worship God."
That's what's soon coming, guys. And
when I see This is huge red flags for
me. When I see
conservative, right-wing political
Christian nationalist wanting to push
and force one world religion.
What did Erica Kirk say at this funeral?
Listen what she said.
Go to church next Sunday and the Sunday
after that.
Pray again. world
and shackles of this day. And the Sunday
after that. And break free from the
temptations and shackles of this world.
Sunday after that.
Go to church next Sunday. And the Sunday
after that.
This
woman is saying this with
a militant spirit.
Go to church next Sunday and the Sunday
after that.
Look, if this is new to you guys, please
watch the micro the The mark of the
beast is not a microchip video.
Watch that video. It's going to to show
you a lot about prophecy, who the beast
is, who the second beast is, what the
mark of the beast is, how it looks so
close to the truth that millions of
Christians are going to fall for it.
Look, I'm not I'm not advocating for a
microchip by any means. I'll never ever
take a microchip under my skin, but I
know and I can
guarantee you
that if I'm rounded up and thrown into a
prison somewhere and I'm
a microchip is forcefully shoved under
my skin, I do not have the mark of the
beast.
The mark of the beast cannot be
forced upon unwilling participants. That
means that man has the power to remove
your salvation because the mark of the
beast is a salvation issue.
The microchip is a great way to enforce
to enforce the mark. It's a great way to
turn off people's ability to buy and
sell, but it currency is not the mark of
the beast. The mark of the beast is
about worship. If you believe in this
one world religion and the beliefs of
your mind, you've taken it in the
forehead. If you don't believe it, but
you say, "Look, if I don't If I don't
just
go to church in the new world church,
then my whole family's going to starve.
I got to do it.
I got to do it. I'm going to take it in
the hand. By the works of my hands, I
received the mark of the beast."
Shadrach, Meshach, and Abednego,
there was a form of worship. Bow to this
image at the sound of the music or else
be thrown into the fire.
And they said, "We don't believe in your
system." They didn't take it in the
forehead. And they could have said, "You
know what? Let's just bow our bodies.
Look, everybody else is doing it. We
don't really worship. We're just going
to do it, you know, just bow our
bodies."
That would have been taking it in the
hand. They said, "We refuse
to break God's second commandment. We
will not bow down to any image. You can
throw us in the fire and God has the
power to save us. And even if he
doesn't, who cares?
We will still serve God and we will not
defile his commandments."
We need to have that kind of strength
and courage and determination in these
last days.
We have to take a stand for truth and
I'm talking about all 10 commandments,
including the fourth commandment.
Remember the Sabbath day to keep it
holy. The seventh day was blessed by God
at creation.
And it has been counterfeited and
changed by the beast, Rome. They openly
admit that
Rome openly admits that we changed the
day of worship.
And all those who who bow to that and
observe that are bowing to Rome.
But it's not the mark of the beast yet.
Praise God, we still have time. The mark
of the beast will be enforced by law,
blue laws, Sunday laws. Look these
things up because they are coming soon.
Thank you guys so much for being in this
late live. We are going to be doing some
speaking engagements out there in
Arkansas. We do a lot of speaking
engagements. People invite us to events
and churches. Next month, we're actually
going to be in Texas at Truther Con
2025. And in November, we're going to be
in Arizona at International Truth Expo.
If you guys would like to invite Candid
Truth to come to your church and give a
presentation on
the pagan origins of of things,
holidays, or the
movies,
the Gnostic gospel that are inside
Disney movies and superhero movies, or
the alien UFO deception,
invite us. Go to candidtruth.org. We
have a booking tab. If you would like to
support this ministry because we are
100%
donation-based. We are not monetized.
You guys will never see a commercial on
our channel because we've been rejected
twice for harmful content by YouTube.
So,
thank you guys. If you have supported
this ministry financially, we cannot
thank you enough.
That's the only reason that we can do
what we're doing here because of
generous donors like you guys. And we
have Cash App, Venmo, Zelle, PayPal, and
Patreon. We cannot thank you guys
enough. We also got some cool t-shirts
and hoodies and mugs and things like
that. If you guys want to go to our
store, we get about $5 commission on
each of those things.
And
we can't do this without you. We love
you. We thank you so much for being
here. If you're new to this channel,
please click subscribe. Click the
notification bell so you won't miss
another video. We touch on current
events and how they tie in with biblical
prophecy. Please give this video a
thumbs up or a thumbs down. I see three
thumbs down. Thank you for that
interaction, guys. It really helps this
video get into the algorithm. And we
will see you next time on Candid Truth.